[Music]
in a world of yearly release cycles
mafia doesn't exactly fit the mold its
debut title the first mafia released in
2002 first time for me foo there's a
first time for everything
the sequel arrived to see magnitude
different than that of its predecessor
2k check had changed games had changed
what it meant to be a mafia game had
changed and now with a new studio at the
helm of the series it's about to change
once again so one of the cliches I throw
around a lot is like if we're not scared
we're doing something wrong why and I
look down and go you know again not to
get up on a soapbox or be - you know we
need about or whatever but is it you
know we do feel like on some level we're
creating art right and and we want
people to think about what it is that
they're playing and at the end of the
day have it resonate with them on you
know levels that go beyond just you know
the visceral moment of like I shot a guy
right and that's certainly in the game
and that's a big part of the game but
games are evolving and we can tell
better stories we can elicit different
types of motion we can elicit a wider
range of emotion so we want to do that
and I think we should be doing that from
the outset you know we kind of were like
look you know we can't be afraid to take
some risks and some chances otherwise
it's just going to be another you know
me - game and and it's gonna get lost in
the shuffle
[Music]
building a new team a new studio new
tack new tools an open-world game you
know it's kind of a crazy speech you
could do in the games industry right
it's not often you get the chance to
build a triple-a studio from the ground
up it takes time money talent and maybe
most of all trust
so when publisher 2k announced that was
building a new internal studio in 2014
to work on Triple A games it came as a
bit of a surprise now in 2016 that
studio is about to release its first
game hangar 13 is pulled talent from
across the world built an experienced
team and taken the reins on an existing
franchise ready to make its mark on the
Mafia series I worked at LucasArts for
years and years right and I got to this
place in my career I started out as a
writer in the industry and so I came in
kind of on the creative side
take them live the Emperor wants to
execute that person
but I got really interested in the
business side and the production side as
well because I felt like in order to
really you know do everything I wanted
to do creatively I had to at least
understand the realities of production
and know what was possible and know when
I was asking for something super insane
or asking for something that was right
at the edge of insanity which is kind of
where you want to be and we you know we
got really fortunate because we were
able to build the studio fairly quickly
you know again we brought over some
folks from 2k check we also were able to
recruit from you know several Bay Area
Development Studios LucasArts where I
worked for several years iseul hayden do
a GDC tool in 2008 which was after he
finished the Force Unleashed I'm heating
black and I'm the project lead on the
Force Unleashed and today I'm going to
walk you through some of the challenges
that we face while working on the Force
Unleashed and he did a big post-mortem
it was actually one of the bigger
sessions at GDC 2008 and it was really
impressive and I kind of at that point
he became apparent to me and I sort of
thought it'd be cool to work with him at
some point the collective experience
here and the number of games people have
worked on you know kind of across the
studio is pretty impressive and I've
been happy with that because we're able
to bring kind of ideas and you know not
just around the games but you know how
games are made and how the studio should
be drawn from a wide you know
variety of talents it's definitely not
common to get the keys to a brand-new
triple-a studio
the great thing about you know what will
hopefully take place over the next
couple of years is that we you know
we've shipped our first game together
which is a huge milestone as a team and
then we'll hopefully get the option this
used to take that to the next level to
expand and then you know see what comes
next
it always has has challenges though you
know you look at you're bringing
together people from very different you
know gaming cultures but also world
cultures right we have a pretty diverse
team you know we're gonna people from
all over the world and again large
contingent 2k Jack and and folks from
you know almost every developed country
in the world working on the team so you
know so we've had to overcome a lot of
kind of culture shock and and you know
what we did it this way here at this
other studio how do we want to do it
here but that's been really interesting
I think again has let us be stronger in
the long run because we get ideas from
all these you know kind of varied groups
when I first started here at 2k and we
you know kind of started with the idea
of hangar 13 we knew early on we wanted
to kind of do three things one we wanted
to go proprietary tackle me for me
that's where I'm most comfortable and
I'm always more comfortable building
tech than trying to shoehorn a creative
vision into you know technology that
already exists
we also knew we wanted to do innovative
open-world games and so you know
open-world games that had some kind of
twist to them
you got
and then the third thing which was
really important to me as we wanted to
kind of advance the idea of this story
are said the player driven experience
the player driven narrative so the
notion that the player is kind of
co-authoring the overall experience so
and we knew all that before we knew that
we wanted to do a mafia game Schofield
is one of the city's most prominent
citizens Remi Duvall you know so we kind
of went into it with with you know first
and foremost what are we in love with
with the Mafia franchise what are the
things for us the the you know really
scream mafia to us and so we took a step
back and we said what are the kind of
franchise builders if we were making a
comic book or a movie or a novel what
are the things that that are you know
have to be done in order for it to be a
true mafia experience so you know we
came up with things like the cities of
living arizo main character we've got to
treat the cities and in character the
it's about organized crime so it's not
about Anarchy it's not about lawlessness
it's it is about criminals but it's
about criminals within a hierarchy and
in a system that has rules that that you
know have to be followed or there's
consequences I watch young money this is
good I will bring you the money and in
exchange you will let me sell heroin in
your city yeah it's an interesting time
for us because obviously we we've tried
really hard to preserve all of the
things that were considered great no I
consider growing hain considered great
about the first games in the series and
the second one it kind of put us put us
in a box in a good way because they
unified us and you know you know the
direction that you need to grow so to
speak and you also understand that
there's certain things in the franchise
that that you can all rally around
universally and then you know kind of
put your stamp on it and move the
franchise forward when we brought like
some of the guys from you know kind of
to K check over they had obviously
worked on mafia 2 so they had a lot of
really good ideas about you know how the
city should be built and and what kind
of constituted a mafia game but
and we wanted because we want to evolve
the franchise so you know we kind of
infused that with a lot of new ideas as
well on the collision of those two
things I think has resulted in a really
unique game but in terms of the
franchise New Orleans actually has a
really long rich history of organized
Italian mafia going back into the 1800s
it actually started not long after the
Civil War and they carried forward up
until you know depend on who you ask
maybe even through today a little bit
but you know even through the the 20th
century there was a mob boss named
Carlos Marcello who was this
larger-than-life figure who ran Italian
mafia in New Orleans eventually who
actually was deported to Central America
and supposedly he walked back so the
government tried a lot to go after him
and they could never really get him in
anything until later in his life but
they did manage to deport him and then
you know one day he just arrives back
and the legend is that he walked was
probably isn't true but you know it
makes for a good story again early on we
wanted to feature a city that was very
diverse
we wanted a protagonist you know in
Lincoln clay who represented a diversity
that we don't normally see I think in
the games industry you could thank me by
calling me by my name die Lincoln to
this then in terms of like the pressure
of launching the Mafia game this is a
person I kind of maintain a fairly
consistent level of stress this is a
part of my life but you know we first
started out like you know it's it may
sound a little corny but it's a big
honor I mean you know the Mafia
franchise has millions of fans around
the world and I think we all recognize
that and we wanted to do our best to
keep the things that fans loved about
the franchise but then move things
forward and involve them you know the
addition of the open-world but I think
for us you know we kind of took a step
back and we said look we could get so
wrapped up and how challenging this
might be that it will second-guess
ourselves at every you know turn so we
can't like we can't we got to kind of
just put that in the back of our minds
and move forward a developer once told
me that you're only as good as your last
game public perception hinges on recent
memory and the last thing you created
could very well make or break your
reputation but what happens when you
haven't made a game yet what happens
when a studio doesn't have a past in the
next two episodes of this video series
we'll explore the game's time and place
and historical fiction from the
political turmoil of the late 60s to the
creation of an American city that can
highlight the complex and sometimes
terrible issues that plagued the era
Blackman and his team may be nervous but
they're hopeful as of now they have a
clean slate as of now there are only
opportunities ahead
and they're waiting in the deep south in
an old city full of history moonshine
and jazz
[Music]
you